[Music]
we talked
in our last conversation
about
hiring and you mentioned that you've
learned how expensive hiring mistakes
can be no doubt you've learned that more
than once so you guys are very strict in
your interviews and you describe the
process i'd love to see if this has
changed and if it is different for
non-technical roles in 2016 it was
number one resume screen good gpa
internships and so on number two two
phone screens which includes problem
solving number three bringing remaining
candidates on site where they have four
different interviews some of which
involve more problem solving as well as
paired programming during which they fix
a bug so this seems to be specific for
technical candidates
i'm wondering if you have anything to
add to this if you could maybe elaborate
on on what
taking your time
and looking for that extra 20
looks like and i suppose i'm most
interested in in non-technical roles
since i am not hiring for for real
technical capabilities but
anything you have to to say on any of
those points would be interesting yeah
that interview is pretty similar to what
we do now i think you know some the
specific actual questions may have
changed a little bit and what we look
for in resumes may have changed a little
bit but it is the overall is pretty
similar and that is for technical
technical hires
non-technical hires it really depends
you know that's that's another thing
about hiring i mean it really depends on
what your
what function you're hiring for so for
example designers
what matters a lot is their portfolio
and the portfolio is this magical thing
portfolios are amazing because within 30
seconds by looking at a portfolio you
can tell a lot like it's just you don't
even have to do all that much
interviewing or anything they just look
at a portfolio yeah it's good
and the other beautiful thing about
portfolios by the way is that it's so
nice because
they're really good for diversity in
that you don't have to know this
person's name you don't have to know
what they look like you don't have to
know anything you don't it's just the
work speaks for itself yeah so this is
the beautiful thing about design but
that's very rare usually you don't
most fields don't have a thing like the
portfolio where you just look at it and
you're like this is it
so you know i i think outside of these
you have to get really good at
interviewing
and you got to figure out
there's a few things that really work
out
one is work product
so
whatever it is that they're supposed to
do you have them do some of that it
could be that they do it offline as in
like they don't have to do it in front
of you it could be like look in order to
apply you have to
you have to
write this thing or whatever it is you
can take your time just send it to us as
part of the application
work product is is really good i i think
that really tells you whether and it has
to be pretty close to what they're
supposed to do when when you hire them
so that's
that's really good i think there's
another one which is just kind of
general intelligence stuff which you may
or may not want to do
but there are some pretty simple kind of
there's this like three question iq test
that you can google for
which is just you know it's not going to
give you an exact precise you know with
just three questions you're not going to
be able to get an exact iq but basically
you know if people can solve this
all three of these questions
they're pretty good with cognitive
abilities
you may want to do that and then the
other one is just kind of more of these
behavioral interviews that you ask these
questions that you really do it does
make a difference for non-technical
stuff i mean things like talk about
a failure
tell me about a time you failed and the
types of things you're looking for is a
do they recognize that they have failed
like the wrong answer the the horrible
ones is this like failure not failure
like when they tell you like i just care
too much yeah yeah or or like it starts
looking like a failure but actually it
was a home run you're like no no no no
like a real failure and so you want to
understand that they understand when
they failed the other thing you want to
hear there is
did they
blame others or themselves
it's very telling when they tell you
about a failure it's a real failure but
they're like but you know what i knew
what to do the whole time
it's just my manager was dumb or
whatever or like so that that's a very
bad sign that because look everybody's
failed and there's at least one instance
usually many where it really was your
fault
i want to hear about that
not about how you always knew all along
and you always write and it's just your
manager sucked or somebody else because
when you do end up hiring them you know
these are the type of people that would
probably blame everybody else for their
failures and you don't want that
so there are these kind of behavioral
interviews that i think really work out
pretty well
so we do we do apply all of those but
you know one of the things that i have
learned a lot
is
and we we employ it at duolingo
when you are the hiring manager so the
person that's actually going to work
with them
and usually it's because you you're
hiring somebody because you'd have a
need you're like well i need a designer
on my team or i need whatever it is i
need
this on my team and i have the need
you're extremely biased
towards hiring
yes
you're like look i just need to get this
done i just want to get it so one of the
things we do is ultimately at duolingo
the decisions are not by the hiring
manager our manager can have a lot of
input but there's somebody else that is
like
a lot of times that's me who's like
i understand you're in deep pain right
now and you need more you know another
person but this person does not pass our
bar
and it's not that i'm that good at the
bar
it's just that i'm a different person so
i make the same mistake when i'm hiring
from you know an executive or something
i have a bias towards hiring because i'm
like man i know i don't want to spend
more time looking for you know this
whatever our head of whatever
by the way we did this for our cfo our
chief financial officer we took a long
time and at some point i almost gave up
i'm like man i'll just take whoever like
it doesn't matter
we didn't do that i was lucky i was
lucky that we'd ended up i mean i had
spent about a year
looking for our cfo yeah it's a long
time
thank god we waited i mean we we our cfo
mats group is amazing uh thank god we
waited but you know in the middle there
after i don't know nine months or so i
started faltering i started being like
just take whoever so it's not that i'm
that good at holding our bar but i'm
very good at holding our bar when it's
not me yeah that makes sense to me
that's a big
big piece of advice have somebody else
hold the bar
you